el plato de la cena deberá estar
dividido en tres secciones iguales
silvera puso brócoli en una sección del
plato nos preguntan qué fracción del
plato tiene brócoli vamos a analizar qué
nos dice este problema dice que el plato
de la cena de verano está dividido en
tres secciones iguales en tres secciones
iguales y además que verá puso brócoli
en una sección del plato y nos preguntan
qué fracción del plato qué fracción del
plato tiene brócoli y bueno qué te
parece si dibujamos el plato para tener
una mejor visión de este problema tal
vez el plato de verano es un rectángulo
bueno realmente no podemos saberlo por
completo no sabemos es un rectángulo
pero un rectángulo va a funcionar
bastante bien y este plato está dividido
en tres secciones iguales así que vamos
a ponerlas por aquí
secciones iguales
una dos tres secciones del plato y
también lo que sabemos es que ella puso
brócoli en una sección del plato así que
vamos a poner por aquí al brócoli
brócoli pro con el brócoli brócoli
brócoli brócoli brócoli en esta sección
del plato así que ya está sombreada con
brócoli y ahora observa esta imagen y
pregúntate lo siguiente qué fracción del
plato tiene brócoli bueno nuestra
fracción va a tener dos partes la parte
de arriba recuerda se llama numerador y
es la cantidad de partes que tienen
brócoli cuántas selecciones tienen
brócoli bueno es una una sección tiene
brócoli y la parte de abajo se llama
denominador y es el número total de
partes iguales en las que está dividido
el plato y bueno nosotros sabemos en
cuántas partes iguales están dividido el
plato
está dividido en tres partes iguales así
que acá abajo va un 3 entonces un tercio
o una de las tres secciones tiene
brócoli